The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: Shall we just
start on this review session?
So, any questions on
anything from Chapter one,
anything from those first seven
lectures is very, very welcome.
So this morning finished
the serious part
of what we'll do in the
chapter with positive definite
matrices.
And we'll see a lot
of those fortunately.
They're the best.
So questions about, I
hope you look in the book,
at other problems
in the problem sets
as well as the ones I suggest.
And then I can, anyway.
Ready for any questions.
Okay.
Which problem is it?
In section?
Section 1.6, problem 27,
what have I done there?
Oh, okay, that's good.
So it's about positive
definite matrices.
May I just put on the board
what the central question is?
Just put these matrices up.
We're given that H and
K are positive definite.
And then the question is, what
about these block matrices.
Do I call them M and N?
One is the block matrix
that looks like that.
And another one is the block
matrix that looks like this.
So those are both symmetric.
We're allowed to ask,
are they positive
definite or negative
definite, because they
passed the first requirement.
They're symmetric.
We can discuss them.
Because of course H and
K each were symmetric.
The transpose of this would
bring K transpose down here,
but that's K, so all good.
So the question now.
Of these guys to those
guys I guess, yes.
Good question.
So this guy has, let's
take eigenvalues first.
So this guy has
some eigenvalues,
say lambda_1 to lambda_n.
And this guy, we'll
suppose they're
the same size, so
they don't have to be.
Maybe I shouldn't, but I will.
This has some other
eigenvalues, maybe
e_1 to e_n for eigenvalue.
And then the question is, okay,
what about the eigenvalues
of that combination?
And what about this?
So it's a good question,
I think for all of us
to practice what just
came up in the lecture.
The idea of block matrices.
So looking here at eigenvalues
I could also look at pivots.
Pivots would be interesting
to look at, too.
Maybe I'll start with pivots.
Can I?
Did you think?
What would be the pivots of M?
If I start elimination on M
what will I see for pivots?
Well, I start up in the usual
left-hand corner and work down.
So what am I going to see first?
I'm going to see the pivots
of H. It won't even know,
by the time I had halfway there,
it won't even have seen K.
And then, that'll be fine.
And then this will be,
what's going to happen?
This is all zeroes.
So never get touched, right?
So when I get down to the second
half I see all zeroes here.
K is still going to be
sitting right there.
Nothing happened.
Because when I did these
eliminations nothing changed
with K. So the
rest of the pivots
will be the pivots of K. Good.
Now, we might hope for the
same thing with eigenvalues
and probably that's
going to happen.
This is like a diagonal matrix.
And actually, what
words would I use?
Block diagonal.
I'd call that matrix
block diagonal.
And those are very
nice matrices.
That tells us that
the big matrix,
for all practical
purposes, is breaking up
into these smaller blocks.
Actually MATLAB will
search for a way
to reorder the rows and columns
to get that in case it's
possible.
So here it's in front of us.
Let's see if we can figure out.
That lambda_1, I believe,
is also an eigenvalue of M.
So it was an eigenvalue
of H. So that this,
the fact that it has that
eigenvalue lambda_1 means what?
That H times this times some
vector y is lambda_1*y, right?
If that's an eigenvalue
it's got an eigenvector
and let's call it y.
Now this is a good question.
I believe this block matrix
also has eigenvalue lambda_1,
and what's its eigenvector?
What could I
multiply M by to get
lambda_1 times the same thing?
Can you see what?
Of course I'm thinking
that y is going to help
but it's grown now.
So what would be the
eigenvector here?
When I multiply by M
it'll just come out right
with the same eigenvalue?
y_1, or y rather, and then?
And then zero, good. [y; 0].
Because if I multiply, can
I put in what M really is?
The H and K. H there, K there.
When I do that multiplication
I get lambda_1*y.
When I do this
multiplication, see I've just,
that's a zero block,
zero, so I got a zero.
Perfect.
So the eigenvectors of H just
sit with a zero in the K part
and produce an
eigenvector of the block
matrix with the same lambda_1.
So you can see then, we
get the whole picture.
The eigenvalues are
just sitting there
and the eigenvectors are there.
Now maybe you got all
that and wanted-- well
I haven't said anything
about N, Sorry.
Everybody thinks more about
N. So what's the thing with N?
What would you say about N?
If you look at that matrix,
suppose I don't even tell you
it's positive definite
at first, would you
say that looks like a
invertible or singular matrix?
Everybody's going
to say singular.
And why would you
say that's singular?
Well, the determinant of a block
matrix, this morning I said
do whatever you like
with block matrices.
But I have to admit that if I
had a bunch of general blocks,
if I had to take the determinant
of that, and of course
everybody's remembering
Professor Strang doesn't like
determinants, if I had
to take the determinant,
I'd have to do the whole thing.
The separate determinants would
not tell me the story, usually.
So determinants
are a bit tricky.
But up here the determinant
will come out zero.
I guess what I would hope your
internal test for a singular
matrix is, are the
columns independent?
And then the matrix
is invertible.
Or are they dependent?
Do you have some
columns that are
in the same direction as
other columns, same direction
as combinations
of other columns?
If you look at the columns
of that, say column one,
so column one is the first
column of K repeated.
What do you think about the
columns of that matrix, that
block matrix N?
Do you see that same
column showing up again?
Yeah.
That very same column, which
is the first column of K,
again twice, is going to show up
right there, first column of K
again.
So this matrix has
two identical columns.
No way it could be invertible.
And in fact, you can
tell me what vector,
I'm always saying are
the columns independent?
Here, no, they're dependent.
And then you can tell me an x.
So this is my block
matrix N. I want
to know an x so that
the result is zero.
That's really my
same indication.
We found two identical columns.
What would be the x?
Well, you have to tell me
more than one, minus one
because I've got a big x there.
Yeah I've gotta
make it big enough,
but essentially it's the
one, minus one, thanks.
And enough zeroes in there
and enough zeroes in there.
So the fact that that
vector gets taken to zero
is the same thing as saying that
one of this column minus one
of this column gives zero.
In other words, the
columns are the same.
And of course, by
doing this we're
seeing the one and minus one
could have gone into position
two there, position three.
So we've got a whole
bunch of vectors.
This matrix N, this [K, K; K, K]
has got a whole lot of vectors
that it takes to zero.
What I would say it
has a large null space.
A large space of vectors
that it takes to zero.
So that's a really
useful exercise.
I'm delighted you asked it.
Now I'm ready for more.
Could do.
Exactly, row reduction.
I should look to see what
would happen in elimination.
Well, elimination would
go swimmingly along
for the first part because
it's only looking here.
But then what would I have after
the first half of elimination?
Well I'd have I suppose whatever
that K changed to, elimination.
What should we call it?
U or something?
When I did these row
steps that matrix
turned into this upper
triangular matrix.
And maybe you can tell me
what will have happened
at the same time to the rest?
What will I see sitting here if
I just do ordinary elimination
and I'm just looking
there and using the pivots
and so on, I'll see?
It'll be U because whenever
I do on the left side
I'm doing to the whole row.
And now, the main point
is, what will I see?
Now elimination, keep
going, keep going.
Do elimination to
clear out this column,
this whole bunch, right?
Elimination.
And now what am I going
to see in that corner?
All zeroes, right.
So that's telling me
that the matrix has just
got half of the eigenvalues
positive, half of the pivots
are positive.
The second half all zeroes.
So I guess, here I've
found an eigenvector
with what eigenvalue?
That's looking like
an eigenvector to me
if we're thinking eigenvectors.
And what's the eigenvalue
that goes with it?
Zero.
Because Nx is 0x.
You can either think of it as
Nx=0 if you're thinking about
systems of equations.
Or Nx=0x if you're thinking that
that guy is an eigenvector with
eigenvalue zero.
So I'm pretty happy.
I mean many of you
will have spotted this.
Probably perhaps all.
But I'm happy that's
an example that
just shows how you
have to think big
with block matrices I guess.
Good.
Okay on that?
What else, thanks.
That's true.
And that's really all I've done
so far is those four examples.
I think that language of
fixed-fixed and fixed-free
really comes, I mean I used
it early about those four
matrices, but it's
really going to show up
at the next lecture,
Friday, when
I have a line of springs and the
matrices that come out of that.
So Friday we'll finally
be on those first four.
A fifth matrix will appear
in this course finally.
Of course, it's going to be
related to the first ones,
naturally, but we'll move
to, we'll see something new
and then we'll see the
fixed-free idea again
for those.
So if that can
wait until Friday,
you'll see some different ones.
Good.
Questions, thoughts.
You can ask about anything.
Maybe I can ask.
Any thoughts about the
pace of the course?
This is sort of a heavy dose
of linear algebra, right?
Of course, the answer
maybe depends on how much
you had seen before.
So those who haven't seen very
much linear algebra at all
really got quite a
bit quickly here.
Because many courses
on linear algebra
never reach this key idea
of positive definiteness
that ties it all together.
So you've seen
quite a bit, really.
Of course, we've concentrated
on symmetric matrices
and there's a whole
garden or forest or zoo
of matrices of different types.
So what matrices have we seen?
Symmetric matrices and
then their eigenvectors
were orthogonal and we
could say orthonormal.
So that gave us, I
don't know if you
remember this part, which
when we wrote it down I said,
big deal.
That's very important.
That's this principal
axis theorem.
These Q's, what kind
of a matrix is Q?
It's the eigenvector matrix.
And for symmetric matrix, so
this is the eigenvector matrix.
And what do we know about it?
In the special case
of symmetric K?
What do we know especially
about the eigenvectors then?
They're orthogonal.
We can make them orthonormal.
So this will be an
orthogonal matrix.
And that was a matrix
with Q transpose
was the same as Q inverse.
Normally we would see
the inverse there,
but for these we can
put the transpose.
Here's one type of matrix,
symmetric, very important.
Here's another type of
matrix, orthogonal matrices.
And of course, many,
many other varieties.
Well here we have
a very nice matrix,
so that matrix is diagonal.
Right, that's just
the eigenvalues,
so that's a diagonal matrix.
And what do we know, if K is
positive definite, let's just,
this was for any symmetric one.
So what's special if K
is positive definite?
Somehow the positive
definiteness
should show up here.
And where does it show?
Positive eigenvalues, exactly.
The Q could be any,
any Q would be fine.
But we would see
positive eigenvalues.
Oh, here's a little
point about eigenvalues.
Suppose I have my matrix K.
And it's got some eigenvalues.
Now let me add four
times the identity to it.
What are the eigenvalues now?
What are the eigenvectors now?
What's changed and how
and what hasn't changed?
Because that's a pretty
easy, the identity matrix
is always the easy one for
us to know what's happening.
So what is happening
to the eigenvalues now?
If K had these
eigenvalues lambda,
what are the
eigenvalues of K+4I?
You add?
You add four, yeah.
The eigenvalues of this are
the eigenvalues of K plus four.
That is just like
shifting the matrix,
you could think of
it is adding four
along the diagonal
will add four.
And the eigenvectors would
be exactly the same ones.
I would have Kx would
agree with lambda*x.
And 4Ix would agree with 4x.
So that proves it.
Good to see what you can do,
the limited number of things
that you're allowed
to do without changing
the eigenvectors, and therefore
you can spot the eigenvalues
right away.
The limited things
you can invert,
you can shift like this, you
could square it, cube it,
take powers, things like that.
I'm going to look to you now for
giving me a lead on something
that is interesting or not.
Yes, thanks.
Go ahead.
Oh, I see okay, yes.
I see.
Alright.
So that's page 64 of the book.
Well, so that's a problem
that physicists love.
I don't know how much I
can say about it here,
to tell the truth.
Just to mention.
Do they use a minus sign?
Probably they do.
So their equation is minus the
second derivative of u plus (x
squared)*u, and they are
interested in the eigenvalues,
equal lambda*u.
The case that we've done in
class was without this (x
squared)*u term, right?
The absolutely most important
case is the second derivative
of u equal lambda*u.
The eigenvalues
were, or what were
the eigenvectors in that case?
What were the eigenvectors of
the second derivative before
there was any (x squared)*u,
any potential showing up?
They were just sines
and cosines, right?
Sines and cosines
have the property
that if you take two
derivatives you get them back
with some factor lambda.
Now let me just
look at that problem
without saying much about it.
First of all, the first
thing I want to know
is have I got a
linear problem here?
Have I got a linear equation?
Because that's where I
talk about eigenvalues.
So in the matrix case,
I'd say I have a matrix.
K times an eigenvector.
That matrix represents
something linear.
It's just, all the rules
of addition work here.
Here it is linear.
It is linear.
What I'm trying
to say is, I just
call that a variable coefficient
and that's what we're
going to see in Chapter two.
The material or something could
lead to some dependence on x.
But u is still
there, just linearly.
In other words, this is a
perfectly okay linear operator
and am I imagining that
it's positive definite?
Let's see.
This part with the minus sign
was positive definite, right?
Well, at least semi-definite.
So let me just remember
the most important case.
If I look at this equation,
d second u/dx squared equals
lambda*u.
So that's the eigenvalue,
eigenfunction problem
for our good friend.
What do I say about
the eigenvalues now?
What can you tell me about
the eigenvalues of that?
Mostly positive.
Because they were
sort of omega squares.
But I mean zero could
be an eigenvalue, right?
What would the eigenfunction
be for lambda equal zero?
If I wanted to get
zero here, if I
wanted a zero on the right
side, what functions u
could give me zero?
Constant function.
Yeah, the constant
function is certainly there
as a possibility.
But anyway, I would say this
is positive semi-definite
at least.
And this part?
How do I think about
that as a big matrix?
I think of it sort of like
a big matrix with x squared
running down the diagonal.
With a matrix, you could say
walking down the diagonal
because it's n steps.
For differential
equations, maybe running
is the right word.
Because it doesn't jump,
it's just bzzz all the way
from zero squared to whatever.
Anyway, that would correspond
to a diagonal matrix, but not
constant diagonal.
Diagonal, but not
Because this x squared
number is changing.
It's like a spring,
it's like a bunch
of springs in which
the first spring maybe
has a spring constant of one.
And then we have a tighter
spring and then a very tight
spring and so on, more and
more, higher and higher
constants there.
Well, I'm just speaking
very roughly here.
Because variable coefficient,
variable material properties,
springs of different
elasticities,
we're ready to move to that.
Our problems up to now, the
springs were all the same.
The bar, if it was
a bar, was uniform.
And now this would
be a step forward.
But now, of course,
this specific problem
just happens to have a
solution that physicists love.
It has a meaning to
physicists, not to me.
And the eigenfunctions
have a meaning
and they're famous functions.
It's just glorious.
So you could say that's the
special problem, the way we
had four special
matrices in 18.085,
that would be a similar special
problem in quantum mechanics.
Let's turn to something
entirely different.
Questions about any topic.
Or I can ask some and
you can take this, maybe
that's one way to review.
Go ahead.
Thanks.
Number 20 of 1.6.
1.6 is a section, oh, no.
That's positive definite
notes so I'm okay with that.
I see that I did ask you
a question on the homework
from 1.7 which I may not
get to cover in lecture,
but give it a shot anyway.
So what's 20?
Oh, okay, that's good.
Without multiplying
out the matrix.
So it's this
Q*lambda*Q transpose.
So I'm telling you
in that question what
Q, lambda, and Q transpose are.
The Q is this [cosine, minus
sine; sine, cosine].
The lambda is two and five,
I think, in that question.
And the Q transpose of course
is [cosine, sine; minus sine,
cosine].
And if I've told you that
those are the numbers then you
could multiply those together
to get K. But you can tell me,
this is like K exposed.
The matrix is like, we're
told more than we would know.
If I multiply it all
together, I wouldn't
see that the eigenvectors
are these guys,
that the eigenvalues
are these guys.
So what, without
looking to see, what
are the eigenvalues
of this matrix K if we
multiplied it all together?
What would the
eigenvalues actually be?
Two and five, right, because
we built it up that way.
What would the determinant be?
Now what do we know
about determinants?
It would be ten is
the right answer.
What's the right
way to see that?
Well, the determinant is always
the product of the eigenvalues,
isn't it?
These guys have
determinant ten anyway.
And if I hadn't normalized,
so this had some bigger
determinant, this would have
some smaller determinant.
Their inverses,
their determinants
will give me the one
and there's the ten.
What else could I ask about
or did I ask about for that?
The eigenvectors, okay.
The eigenvectors of the
matrix, what are they?
They're these columns that
are sitting here for us,
they're those two
columns, right.
And would you like to just
check that if the-- I believe
that column is an eigenvector.
And which do you think, two
or five, is its eigenvalue?
That goes with
this first column.
Everybody's going to say
two and that's right.
And do you want me to just take
that matrix times this proposed
eigenvector and just see
if it's going to work?
Suppose I just do
all and just see,
sure enough this will
be an eigenvector.
So what do I have at this point?
Can you do this
times this first?
What do I get? c squared
plus s squared is one.
And -cs plus cs is zero.
So at that point I have [1, 0].
Now comes this matrix.
So what do I have after that
matrix speaks up? [2, 0].
And now I take two times
this and what do I get?
Or that matrix times the [2, 0].
How do you multiply a matrix
times that [2, 0] vector.
Here's the good
way to think of it.
It's two times the first column.
And zero times the second.
So the net result
of the whole deal
was two times that first column.
Which is exactly saying
that this is an eigenvector.
When I did all that
it came back again.
Scaled by two.
So that's a good example.
And then, is the matrix
positive definite?
That connects to
today's lecture.
What test would you use
to show that the matrix is
positive definite?
The eigenvalues, yeah.
The eigenvalues
are sitting there.
Two and five, both positive.
If I changed one of those
signs, then it would no longer
be positive definite.
It would still be symmetric,
I'd still have the eigenvectors,
but the eigenvalue would
have jumped to minus five.
I think this sort of helps out.
I guess I hope that as
I'm doing these things,
you're ahead of me or
with me in the calculation
and you just have to
do a bunch of these
to get confidence that
you've got the right thing.
Okay, yes?
1.6, 24.
Is that also a homework problem?
Alright, but you guys are
reading the rest of the book,
right?
Not only the homework questions.
Ah.
Oh, dear.
24, that's a very good question.
About this, yeah.
Right.
It's a good question.
And if today's lecture had
been, well it ran a little late.
But if we ran another 20 minutes
late, I could have done this.
I'll just say what's
in that problem.
And then we'll see it again.
So what's in that question?
Let me write down what it is.
So I have a positive
definite matrix K, right?
And then I've got its energy.
I'm using u rather
than x, so let's use u.
So my u transpose Ku, or
like x transpose Kx today.
That is this bowl-shaped
figure, right?
If I graph this on
the u_1, u_2 maybe up
to u_n, all in the base.
And now I have the picture.
So I'm in n+1 dimensions.
The other dimension is this one.
Then that's the one where I
might get this bowl-shaped guy.
And I've called that energy.
In many, many physical problems
there is a factor of 1/2.
And it's going to be nice
to have that factor of 1/2.
So that won't change
anything, just half as big.
So what is the minimum
value of that energy?
And what is the minimum value of
this, if I said minimize that,
you could do it right away.
It'd be a zero.
Now I'm going to
introduce a linear term.
This was a quadratic term
and it had u squareds in it.
So the linear term is
going to be u transpose f
is the shorthand for it.
And of course, we all know
that that stands for u_1*f_1,
u_2 all minus,
u_2*f_2 and so on.
However many dimensions I'm in.
You can imagine I'm
in two dimensions.
So it's -u_1*f_1 - u_2*f_2.
So what I'm saying is
that minimizing just this
was like, too easy, right?
The answer was zero.
Nobody's interested
in that for very long.
But now it is much
more interesting
when I get a linear
term in there.
So what happens now?
Well, the effect
of that linear term
is to shift that bowl sorta
over and down a little.
So that instead of sitting where
I drew it, let me erase it.
If I now graph this function,
this is my function of u,
this is still the
most important part,
but now I have a
first order term.
And the result is, it
still goes through here.
Right?
Why does it still go
through that same point?
Because if I take u_1 and
u_2 to be zero, I get zero.
So I still get zero there.
But the bowl has shifted.
It's more like something here.
And it still has a minimum
because this is still
the all-important term.
But it's just moved
over and down.
So it has the minimum value.
It actually goes below
zero, but if I look at it
if I'm sitting at the
minimum and looking
I'm seeing a bowl
going up, right.
So I hope that picture shows--
And now, of course, that's
the geometry.
In other words, the
same geometry just
moved the thing over and down.
But the algebra is,
where is the minimum?
What is the value
of that minimum?
And this problem, 24, is
one way to do the minimum.
One way to do it.
But actually, if you
didn't like linear-- well
I won't say didn't like
linear algebra, that's
against my religion.
So if you like calculus and
you said, wait a minute,
if you give me something
you want me to minimize,
what will I do?
I'll set derivatives to zero.
And can I just
jump to the answer?
Oh, what derivatives do I set to
zero now, for the minimum here?
It's the first derivatives.
And they're first
derivatives with respect to?
I look at df/d what?
You see I've already
given it away.
These are going to be
partial derivatives.
Why's that?
Because I've got two directions.
So I have a df/du_1=0
and a df/du_2=0.
In other words, when I
sit here at the bottom
I'm seeing this
whole bowl above me.
If I go along the u_2
direction it should go up
and if I come along the
u_1 direction, goes up.
But it's flat at the
bottom both ways.
So what's my point here?
If you like calculus,
you'll get to two equations.
And I just want to say
what those equations are,
because they're all important.
Suppose we only had
u_1 and nothing else.
Then this would just be a
parabola and the derivative
of this would be
at 1/2 K*u squared.
Suppose n is one.
I'm only in one.
So what's the derivative
of 1/2 K*u squared?
The derivative.
So I'm looking for, if this
was 1/2 K*u squared and I took
the derivative with
respect to u, it would be?
It'd be Ku.
And it works here
in the matrix case.
And what would be the derivative
of u, transpose of u times
f, if u was just a number and
if u was just one thing and f
was a single number, the
derivative would be? f, yeah.
It'd be f.
That's the system.
I've jumped to the answer.
That this set of two or n
equations in matrix language
would just be, and I'll even
write it better as Ku=f.
That tells me where
the minimum is.
The minimizing guy is,
so this is in the base
and then the thing
is dropping down.
I still have to figure out
what's the bottom value.
But I've now identified
where the minimum occurs.
So you get two questions
about a minimum.
Where is it?
What value of u
gives the minimum?
And at that point, at that
lowest point, how low is it?
The one thing you've
gotta remember
is that when you
minimize that quadratic,
you get that system
of equations.
And then, of course, the answer,
you have to solve that system.
But this goes back
to what I said
at the first minute of today.
That we have two ways
of looking at a problem.
Usually we go directly
to the equations.
Sometimes the problem
comes naturally to us
as a minimum problem.
Like we have to
minimize the cost,
we want to build a new
school or something.
So we've got some
cost function that we
minimize that will lead, through
calculus or linear algebra,
to this.
So I've done everything
but answer the question 24.
We only checked
the one by one case
to see that that's
the right equations,
derivative equal zero.
And now you could use
calculus as I said.
But if I answer that question,
well let me just do a little.
The idea of that question
24, so that was what?
1.6, 24, or something.
Is that right?
Yeah.
Is that I could rewrite
this to make it clear.
I think it's u
minus K inverse f,
transpose K times u
minus K inverse f.
And then a minus 1/2 f
transpose K inverse f.
Actually, my best friend in
China told me this trick.
And I didn't give him
credit for it in the book.
But I should have done.
I just think that if you
multiply all this out,
you'll get this.
It's what I would
call an identity.
That just simply means that
it's just true for every u.
It's true for everything.
Can I try to multiply
some of that out?
Just so you kind of see it.
Yeah, that's what I
mean, multiply it out.
You've got it.
This thing would
give me four terms.
It'd be this transpose
times that times that.
Which is my guy here.
And then I'll have something.
It's just like numbers.
Then this thing times
that times this.
And this thing times
that times that.
Let me do that last one.
What happens when I do
the 1/2 and this transpose
times the K times this.
So I'm using the
distributive, whatever, laws.
Let's just do that
particular term
and see what we're getting.
So I have 1/2 of the minus
K inverse f transpose.
So how do I write that?
Shoot.
Well, it's something
times something transpose.
So what do I have to do?
Opposite order.
So I have a minus, an F
transpose and the K inverse
transpose.
You're seeing all this stuff.
And then comes the K and
then comes the minus,
oh again the minus.
So that'd be a plus, right?
Times K inverse times f.
So that's one of the terms.
That's one of the
terms that shows up.
And what good is that one?
So that's one.
You could say that's
the longest term.
That's the one with
the messiest term.
But you can fix it.
What would you do with that?
K times K inverse is?
Identity.
So we can forget that.
And now we're there.
That's 1/2, f transpose,
f on this side.
Oh, what's K inverse transpose?
It's the same as K inverse
because K is symmetric,
so its inverse is symmetric.
So that transpose doesn't
change the matrix.
In other words, this term will
show up and this term is oh!
Nope, sorry.
I was going to goof here.
I was going to say this
is the same as this,
but it's not, right?
Why not?
Because it's positive.
And this guy is negative.
Has my good friend
Professor Lin messed up?
Nope.
What's going to happen now?
The two that I didn't
do, you see, the 1/2 u
transpose K u is here.
Then comes this
one, which I didn't
do, and then another
one that I didn't do,
and then this one that I did.
They'll all be the same.
So they'll all contribute with
their plus sign or minus sign
and the net result will
be a perfect match, yeah.
So I won't wear out your
patience by doing that.
But I do want to make the point.
What was Professor Lin's point
in suggesting to write it
in this more complicated way?
His point was we could see
this is just a constant.
Doesn't depend on u.
And now I can see what value
of u would make this as small
as possible.
Remember, I'm still
trying to minimize.
This part, I can't make it
bigger or smaller, it's fixed.
It's u that I can play with.
So what u should I choose
to make this part smaller?
Bear with me.
What u will make this big
mess as small as I can get it
and how small can I get it?
If I take u to be K inverse
f, then this is zero,
this is zero, I get zero.
And that's my claim, that u
equal K inverse f is the best
possible, is the minimizer.
And how do I know
that I can't make this
more negative than the zero?
I can get it down
to zero by making
that to be the zero vector.
But how do I know I
can't make it below zero?
The K is positive definite
and I'm sitting here
with some x
transpose and some x.
The x has this sort of
messy form but it's an x
and here's its transpose.
So this is an x transpose Kx
and can't be brought below zero
when K is positive definite.
Good.
So we've said a good bit
about positive definite here,
but happy to think--
Yeah, thanks.
In fact, finally a fifth.
Exactly.
Thanks, perfect question.
And let me answer it clearly.
Each of those five
tests completely
decides positive definite.
So the five tests
are all equivalent.
If a matrix passes one
test, it passes all five.
So that's great, right?
So we just do
whichever test we want.
Or whichever way we want
to understand the matrix.
I was going to add, I didn't
say a lot about this one.
Can I just add a note
about a MATLAB command?
The command chol(K).
That's the first letters
in the name Cholesky.
So chol is the first four
letters of this name.
And that's a MATLAB command.
If I've defined a matrix
that's positive definite
and I use that command,
out will pop an A,
one particular A that works.
Out will pop an A
that makes this work.
It'll be a square A and
it'll be upper triangular.
So out will pop, so this command
is very, very close to the LU
but it's just sort of
the appropriate version,
symmetrized version
of elimination
when you have a positive
definite symmetric matrix.
If your matrix is not
positive definite,
MATLAB will tell you so.
So it produces one
particular A. There
are many A's that
would work, but there's
one particular upper
triangular one.
It's just related to the
usual U, but yes, thanks.
No, I only even get
into that ballpark
if the matrix is symmetric.
I don't touch it otherwise.
So my matrix is
symmetric before I begin.
So I know good things about it.
And here I'm asking for more.
Here I'm asking are the
pivots all positive?
Are the eigenvalues
all positive?
So that's more.
But I could think of
some interpretation that
would, for
non-symmetric matrices,
but it has problems, so
I'd rather just leave it.
Stay with symmetric.
Well that's two hours of
lots of linear algebra.
I'm hoping you're going to
like the MATLAB problem.
Would you like to
see what it'll be?
I'll just tell you what
the equation will be.
So it'll be a
differential equation.
Oh, dear, what is it?
So it's a differential
equation with a -u''
that we know and love.
And what else has it got?
Oh yes, right.
So here's the problem.
Here's the equation.
So it has the -u'', the second
derivative and it has a first
derivative equal whatever.
In fact, the example will
choose a delta function there.
So what am I talking about here?
This would be a diffusion
and this would be,
anybody met these things before?
That would be a convection.
So that's a first derivative,
that's an anti-symmetric.
The MATLAB problem is now going
to create the difference matrix
for that.
So the symmetric part
will be our old friend K.
But now we've got the
convection term is appearing.
And it's going to
be anti-symmetric.
And if v is big, it gets
more and more important.
So what happens?
What happens with
equations like this?
Really this is like the
first time in the course
that we've allowed this first
derivative term to pop up.
But nevertheless we can see
a lot of what's happening.
And how to deal with
those equations?
I mean, if you ask a chemical
engineer or anybody, they're
always dealing with a flow, like
the Charles River is flowing
along, that's coming
from the velocity there,
but at the same time
stuff is diffusing in it.
It's just a constant problem
in true, true applications.
And this is the
best model, I think.
So you'll see that and
I'm pleased about that.
As you'd see.
Any last question?
I'm always happy.
Well I'll see you Friday then.
Thanks for coming.